the top Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee will work with
the FBI to edit his rebuttal to the
Republican memo released last week on
alleged bias by the bureau and the
Justice Department two weeks ago now
President Trump says he will not
declassify the Adam Schiff document
because it contains too many of the
country's secrets here's chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge those things need to be
redacted House Republicans bank the
White House rejection of the Democrats
memo they say is loaded with national
security sources highly-placed
intelligence asset attended a particular
event in a particular country in a
particular location at a particular time
which it does you know I can figure out
who that intelligence asset is and if I
can our adversaries can a source close
to the process said Democrats can
expedite the review by making the
requested FBI and Justice Department
redactions laid out in these letters
signed by FBI director Christopher ray
and Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein no committee vote would be
required and the memo could go directly
to the president for declassification
however the source said revisions beyond
the recommended redactions would likely
require another committee vote behind
closed doors slowing down the process
ranking Democrats seemed open to changes
we're gonna sit down with the FBI and go
through any concerns that they have and
any legitimate concerns over sources and
methods we will redact over the weekend
president Trump accused Democrats of
laying a trap
including sources and methods that would
have to be removed then allowing
Democrats to accuse the White House of
not being transparent accusations backed
up by the president's aides it's very
clear who's playing politics with
people's lives the Republicans write a
memo which the FBI quite accurately
describes as misleading and omitting
material facts the Department of Justice
says it would be extraordinarily
reckless to release this and what does
the president do he says I'm going to
release it the house intelligence
committees Republican chairman called
the 10-page Democrat memo political
because it characterizes a Trump
campaign adviser as a double agent and
the British spy behind the DNC Clinton
funded Trump dossier as credible they
tack mice myself they attacked chairman
Gowdy they turn carter page into some
super Sikh
Russian spy they talk about how
Christopher steel is a is a really
really good source what do we know that
he lied to the FBI so we want this out
ship also called out Senate Judiciary
Committee chairman chunk Browns Lee who
along with fellow Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham wants the Justice
Department to investigate Steele for
allegedly lying to the FBI Schiff said
the criminal referral really targets the
Russia special counsel it is part of the
same effort along with the chairman of
our committee to try to put the FBI and
Bob Moses investigation on trial
spokesman for Senator Grassley said the
criminal referral is in no way critical
of the Special Counsel investigation and
congressman Schiff should back up his
allegation with evidence or retracted
and apologize for questioning in the
Senators motives right captain thank you